Just this
afternoon, the
state legislature
passed a six week abortion ban.
The bill
when signed,
which Governor Ron
DeSantis has already signaled he will do,
will make abortion access
even more difficult
in the Sunshine State,
which right now
outlaws abortion after 15 weeks.
And Steve King
is with us from Saint
Petersburg, Florida.
And Steve,
the current 15 week ban is on
the books has no exception
for rape and incest.
But this law is a six week ban.
But it would include
exceptions for rape and incest
That's right, Jake, but only to a point.
And opponents of this bill say
it will still make Florida
one of the most restrictive states
in the country to get an abortion.
Let me go through
what this bill actually does.
As you said, it
bans abortion in most cases
after six weeks.
There are exceptions for rape, incest
and for victims of human trafficking.
Up until week 15, but after week 15,
the only exceptions are for
if they're the life
of the mothers at risk
or if there's a fatal defect.
And even then,
you have to get two doctors
to sign off on it.
It also prohibits abortion by telehealth
and via email.
So you can't get medication sent to you
by the Postal Service in Florida.
And then it also requires
the state Supreme Court
to take action
or a change in the Constitution
before this takes effect.
There's a quirk in Florida's constitution
that includes a privacy clause.
And in the past,
the state Supreme Court has interpreted
that to include a right to abortion.
But that Supreme Court
has shifted
dramatically in recent years,
and now Distances has actually appointed
four of the six members
and will get to appoint another one soon.
So, Jake,
where abortion rights advocates
believe that this Supreme Court
is likely to overturn
that privacy
clause, and
and really,
at that point,
it'll be a six week ban in the state
I just saw
polling suggesting that it's a majority.
The American people
oppose a six week ban
and that even among Republicans
it's like 45
45 against it in favor of a six week ban.
I assume that Governor
DeSantis, in addition
to supporting the principles
behind this bill, thinks
this is going to help
him politically, perhaps
Well, certainly if he's going to answer
the Republican primary for president,
that this is an issue
that is often a litmus test.
He is going to be going up against
President Donald Trump,
who appointed several
Supreme Court justices
that overturn Roe v Wade.
But like you said,
this is an issue that Democrats believe
has given them an advantage
and given them some
some tailwinds in recent elections.
We just saw
what happened
in the Wisconsin
Supreme Court race there
and a whole bunch of midterm races.
Abortion loom large as well.
But in Florida,
where Republicans
control both chambers by a large margin,
if the census didn't take action,
it would have been an issue for him
in the GOP primary.
Jake, All right.
Steve Cantor now
in Saint Petersburg, Florida,
thanks so much.
Attorney General Merrick
Garland is preparing
to take the fight over the abortion
pill to the U.S. Supreme Court.
This comes after an appeals
court declined to ban
the abortion drug misoprostol
and in a ruling late last night.
But it made access to the drug
more difficult.
CNN's Joan
Biskupic is with us to explain.
Joan, what did Attorney
General Garland have to say
about bringing this case
before the Supreme Court?
And what's the timeline here? Sure.
Good afternoon, Jake.
This is what the attorney general said
in a statement around noon.
The Justice Department
strongly disagrees
with the Fifth Circuit's decision.
We will be seeking
emergency relief
from the Supreme Court
to defend the FDA's scientific judgment
and to protect
Americans access to safe
and effective reproductive care.
Now, Jake,
we haven't seen the full filing yet,
but I imagine
that the attorney general
will take strong issue with yet
another court second guessing the FDA's
scientific expertize here.
As you know, though,
the validity of the drug dates
to the year 2000
then the restrictions on access
that are an issue they day to 2016.
So we've got a lot in place
and just a reminder
that this medication abortion protocol
is the most common form of
that women are using today in America
to end their pregnancies.
So there's a lot at stake here.
And you know, it's
now going back to the Supreme Court
that completely eliminated
the constitutional right to abortion
and left it to the states.
So medication abortion
is a very crucial part
of that ability for access
also for women
who have suffered miscarriages.
You rely on. Mr.
President, as we mentioned,
this all comes after the ruling
from the appeals court last night,
which didn't ban Mr.
Stone
but kept restrictions around the drug.
What are those restrictions? Exactly.
One would be just in terms of
how how a woman could actually
obtain the drug since 2016,
there was no longer
an in-person
requirement after a woman
had actually met with physician.
Now we're back to
if this
if everything stays
the way
the Fifth Circuit wants it over
the next 24 hours,
no longer
could a woman
get the drug by mail
after the initial consultation
with a physician.
So that's one thing.
And the second thing
is the window for availability
would decrease generally from
currently ten weeks down
to seven weeks of pregnancy.
So those are
those are significant access issues
that would be rolled back
if the Supreme Court does not stop
the effect of the two lower court
decisions.